welcome to a phenomenal conversation
with one of the most brilliant minds
alive today jim alcaley a renowned
scientist theoretical physicist and
popular science communicator jim and i
discussed what does it mean to do
science to follow the science to trust
the science
what does it mean when scientists say
scientists say
these are the topics that impact your
life in a way that almost nothing else
in modern culture does people look to
scientists like jim and they look to us
for answers perhaps to some of the most
meaningful questions about their
day-to-day lives but also for the
existential questions and we got into
that at the very end so jim and i didn't
shy away from controversial subjects
like what to do with models of
controversies such as global warming
covet 19 and many many other fascinating
subjects that scientists are
participating in and with more and more
importance placed upon them we talked
about how he got interested in science
what it means to popularize science do
scientists have a moral obligation to
share the love for that which they would
do for free and i speak for myself and
for jim in saying that i also got into
my patented final thrilling three
questions you'll have to subscribe to my
mailing list at briankeating.com
put the link over there and now i want
to give you a slight insight into this
wonderful new book by jamel khalili
courtesy of his publisher princeton
university press so don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comment what gives
you the most joy about science
[Music]
there's something enchanting even
magical about rainbows would their
wonder be diminished if you understood
how they're formed
what if you knew that the colorful ark
that you admire is really part of a
bigger circle
or why no two people see the same
rainbow
science empowers us to see the world
more completely and deeply
innate short lessons enlighten your mind
and empower your life
unlock the joy of science
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
well today you are all in for a treat as
we speak to professor jim alkalili who
is a fellow of the royal society a
quantum physicist
and holder of the university of surrey
distinguished chair as well as a
personal chair in physics how many
chairs can you have you've got a
university chair a personal chair and a
public engagement of something yeah i've
got a whole three-piece suite i say
you're like a one-man ikea exactly
exactly
uh you uh you live in a three-piece suit
but uh according to your website uh
which i'll link to in the show notes uh
jim how are you today i understand
recovering from the very malady that
caused this book to become instantiated
we'll get into that how are you feeling
right now indeed not too bad thank you i
i have to say i've had worse cold so i i
got off quite lightly actually snuffly
nose bit of a chesty cough but i'm i'm
i'm fine oh that's wonderful i'm so glad
to hear you're you're feeling well and
rested and so forth so i am uh going to
try to be mindful of your time because i
know uh it's a very gracious of you to
spend any time here but we have a new
book that's coming out called the joy of
science this episode will be released uh
hopefully the day of the book release
and we will uh we will make sure to
publicize it uh as it is due for so i
want to start off by doing
what you're told never to do in life
which is to judge a book by its cover
so jim
tell me
what is the origin of this book's title
subtitle and the the awesome cover
design as well
well yes i mean i had all all a whole
list of different titles that i
suggested to my publishers princeton
university press
and it was about you know rationalism
the scientific method and none of them
really sort of resonated or sort of
captured the imagination and then my
editor princeton suggested the joy of
science
uh and it really because i mean it is a
celebration of
why science is so important why we
scientists
do what we do
how it gives us this a better
understanding and empowerment because we
can understand more about how the world
is you know enlightenment over ignorance
but it's also a book about
how we do science the scientific method
and the fact that if we could
use some of the techniques that we use
in science when science is done properly
in daily life i think it would make
everyone you know the happier you know
the idea of you know importance of doubt
and uncertainty the importance of
examining your evidence being prepared
to change your mind so it's eight
lessons from the scientific method so
that's
one of the reasons why you have sort of
the letter eight two circles on on the
cover
and and the other is the at the very
beginning i use an example i'm not the
first author to do this you know people
like um carl sagan certain music talking
about the the beauty of the rainbow
uh and and why you know when the poet
keats criticizes newton by saying you
know you've you've destroyed exactly
exactly you know that the the
breaking light into its prismatic colors
and weaving the rainbow and weaving yeah
and and you destroy the beauty and the
poetry of it and rubbish you know the
feynman talks about this very eloquently
it doesn't it adds it adds to the beauty
so that there's the colors of the
rainbow there on the on the book as well
yeah i found that quite lovely the book
is a delight it's a quick read i
actually because i don't think it's
available yet on audiobook format i
actually put it into an app called
speechify and i listened to a british
accent voice and it was really
delightful uh this book can be consumed
with delight in just a few hours uh and
and yes those characters speak vividly
through the book
as well as uh some of their maybe
counterpoints and and maybe i want to
start with the battle epic battle
between walt whitman and and richard
feynman you know the learned astronomer
versus the learned physicist and and of
course feynman as you quote says you
know do i care less about jupiter
because i know
he's not a god and made of methane no uh
so i taught a class here with a pulitzer
prize winner by the name of ray
armentrout who's a poet and we taught a
class called uh called poetry for
physicist which is the exact opposite of
what you normally teach but i wonder how
much
can we learn from our poetic friends as
as your countryman uh paul dirac said
you know
something like you know poets attempt to
do explain the most
simple things in the most obtuse
obfuscational language possible and in
science the joy is doing just the
opposite so yeah so explain that tension
that fundamental tension um yeah i mean
i don't see that tension i i start off
in the book and saying
first of all science isn't a collection
of facts that's called knowledge
science is the process by which we
acquire that knowledge but i also
acknowledge that there are other ways
that we gain
knowledge enlightenment and wisdom we
know and it could be through poetry or
art or literature or music or
contemplation or religious texts or
um
just discussing and debating with our
fellow human beings
science is one way and when it comes to
the the the the
natural sciences you know our area of
physics for example um science i believe
is the most reliable way of getting to
understand the nature of of
of physical reality out there
poetry is a is a is a tool that can
bring that to life can add to the
narrative to add to the story of how the
way the world is but i
i don't think poetry detracts from our
ability to understand i think it
enriches in the way that science also
enriches our understanding so different
different ways of looking at the world
yeah then hopefully they can complement
each other and absolutely lead to some
uh some further um you know warfare um
so you mentioned you know knowledge and
of course you know the word science in
latin means siencia means uh means
knowledge but it doesn't mean wisdom
that's what sapien or sapienza means so
you know do you think at some level
enough uh knowledge can kind of convert
you to to having wisdom in other words
is there a is there a quantity after
which you assume such amount of quantity
of knowledge that you actually become
wise are they fundamentally blocked off
from one another
i i don't think they're the same thing i
mean that that they are connected with
each other the more knowledge and
experience you have i would suggest
they're correlated you should be more
rather than less wise but i don't think
wisdom is something that can be acquired
if if you know someone who knows nothing
about a particular
area or discipline if they could
absorb all the knowledge and information
about that discipline that doesn't make
them wise that doesn't make them
i i like that the fact that for me at my
stage in my in my career i'm now leaning
more towards offering wisdom to my my
young students rather than you know the
knowledge they're smarter they're faster
than me they can remember stuff i've
forgotten more than they've learned but
i hope that i can offer wisdom and i
don't think that's the same thing as
because i have an accumulation of
knowledge but they are connected they
are connected
what do you how do you react to this
statement i'm gonna i'm gonna drop on
you follow the science what does that
mean to you
yeah it it
it's it's the the phrase that has been
used by politicians particularly during
the pandemic over the last two years to
somehow absolve themselves of any
responsibility you know if they
don't follow sensible policies just to
say we are following the site it's
meaningless i mean you
say we are following the advice of
scientists uh
based on our current understanding fine
but i i
if that's what they mean and they've
just shortened it down to follow the
science three words fine but i worry
that politicians don't actually
understand
the science you know following the
science means doing doing science means
following the scientific method you're
not doing that you're listening to
someone giving you advice which chances
are you going to ignore
[Laughter]
now in your opinion uh you know i always
get kind of um reaction to this you know
that there is no real
one scientific method i mean you don't
go down and you know i don't go down to
my laboratory and say no i'm going to
test the hypothesis and then i'm going
to acquire uh and and actually they're
in my estimation i mean you're you're
you know far better qualified to answer
but there's multiple scientific methods
there's deductive there's inductive um
what is this what is the scientific
method is it just a rubric is it just a
shorthand or is it a shibboleth what is
it exactly i i certainly think it's it's
it's a
a collection of all the ways that we've
used across the disciplines that we call
scientific disciplines to gain more
knowledge but i there isn't
it's certainly not a you know a tick a
box ticking exercise and say you know
what does it mean to be a scientist well
you have to be curious about the world
well you know a conspiracy theorist is
curious you know it
it's about gathering evidence and and
well the conspiracy theorists think
they're being rational and gathering
evidence and being skeptical and so on
um is it about testing a hypothesis
against you know you come up with a
narrative hypothesis test it against
observation well the historian does that
as well does that mean history is part
of science no it means they're using the
same techniques to learn something about
the nature of the past as opposed to the
nature of physical reality around us so
there isn't
uh uh um a list of things it's some
areas of science require
you know falsifiability or reproduce
reproducibility and so on other areas
require testing of hypotheses and
coming up with a theory that has
predictive power but even you know
having predictive power is not enough
you know your
your your star signs you're you're
reading your astrological star chart may
say
you're going to get promotion next
tuesday when you're going to work and
sure enough your boss gives you
promotion oh look it predicted correctly
therefore astrology is a science well
you know
there isn't one-size-fits-all it is a
you're right it's a nebulous term that
can mean different things depending on
the sort of science that we're doing
yeah
so last year past guest on the show lord
martin reese
told me you know
pertinent to astronomic astrology that
you know he's responsible as the
astronomer royal to tell the queen her
horoscope i thought that was really nice
uh i'd like to have that gig you know
for the president here i'd like to be
the federal astronomer um but but in
reality yeah there there is as as we
maybe pivot to a subject that you you
bring up in the joy of science uh you
know this this kind of fascination with
with karl popper and and this
falsification and you just pointed out
you know uh not only could such a
prediction of a soothsayer as popper
called them come true but it's also
falsifiable if you didn't get the raise
so then his hypothesis was falsified
therefore it's science what gives i mean
what what how much should we put on
popper i mean in my understanding he
didn't even think we should put that
much effort emphasis on falsification as
the cinequa non
i think when i was a student um it was
always argued that you know the two the
great philosophers of science of our age
were karl popper and thomas kuhn you
know the the paradigm shift ideas i
think these days this notion that papa's
idea of falsification isn't held at in
such high regard you know put on a
pedestal like it used to you know we're
we're much more careful now talking
about you know being good bayesians you
know that having you know
uh
priors you know that what's the
probability that this idea is right well
based on what your initial assumptions
were surely and what's the probability
that they were right um
the the idea of falsification i i'd use
the example in the in the book which is
that many people have used before you
know all swans are white
you see one one brown swan and and you
say see that that
suggests that you know it falsifies your
theory that all spawns away but then how
do you know that brown swan is it just a
white swan caked in mud
you know so that the the falsifying
counter example itself may not be
correct you know and we've seen this in
physics you know you
the famous experiment of the faster than
like neutrinos a few years ago
yes
yeah they are opera experiment you know
they detected these particles that
looked like they were getting from a to
b faster than the speed of light oh
einstein's wrong you know
and then but it turns out the experiment
itself was wrong there was a loose cable
behind one of the the the counters in
the computer so that's right just having
one fault yeah so falsification is is uh
probably not
not as a strong uh um a definition of
what good a good scientific theory
should be
and then you mentioned you know a
frequent character in all popular books
uh in addition to feynman and
and uh and galileo and newton uh you
mentioned einstein just a second ago and
uh chapter uh chapter
five in this wonderful book is called
entitled don't value opinion over
evidence and i wonder if we could talk
about authority my favorite scientist of
all time is galileo who said uh in
matters of science the uh you know the
issues of authority cannot uh overcome
the humble reasoning of a lone
individual of course i get that all the
time yesterday alone i mean i posted on
my twitter you know i'm going to be
talking to you and uh i got all sorts of
quiet like people want me to ask you
about their theories about you know
conscious electrons and this thing and
we'll get to some audience questions
don't don't worry because that is part
of my hallmark on this channel uh but
nevertheless um you should also have
some respect for authority and science
as feynman or sagan i can never remember
which one said um you know i'd rather
have you know answers uh that questions
that cannot be answered than answers
that cannot be questioned to me that's a
canard against you know religion um but
i wonder you know do we worship you know
this guy a little bit over much uh are
we kind of infatuated in fact in the
public when we see things like the
during the coronavirus that you just
mentioned or with the iran nuclear deal
they trot out 70 nobel prize winners you
know 11 of whom have been on my show uh
you know and they'll just trot them out
and then we're supposed to say okay
we'll just do what you say and all these
matters even though you're a condensed
matter physicist talking about a vaccine
that's you know mnra anyway
to what level should the general
layperson experience a little bit of the
joy of science by questioning the
authorities even this guy
so i mean first of all
having is something we see on social
media more and more these days you know
valuing opinion over evidence is is a is
a worry
and it's true that you know
you know when my plumber comes around to
fix my boiler and he says i know what's
wrong with it uh you know there's this
error it means you've got to change this
the circuit board
i don't say to him don't worry you know
i've had a look on youtube i know
exactly what so i can do it myself you
know
i'm a theoretical visitor
everything is made of quarks surely i
must
i must be able to forget i know so much
more than you could
let me just ask you um
skin was a plumber so oh well now right
right okay so yeah everybody so he can
do that he can say that but the rest of
us know so to some extent you have to
say look someone has expertise because
they've had years of study and and
thinking about this and you can't just
come to it and say what right does this
person have to say that they're right
and i'm wrong
um you know i i'm sure you get
the same as me we get the emails and the
letters from people saying
i have no background or in physics
however you know i've proven einstein
wrong well you know e equals m c cubed
you know not cubed you know not m c
squared and if you help me i'll share
the nobel prize with you yeah but i'm
not telling you yet because you know
that's right you have to help me get my
stuff up anything ah
so that so you know you don't want to
insult people some of these
these people are very earned and genuine
and they've spent years thinking about
this stuff but they haven't had the
benefit of of you know doing a
proper course on in physics for example
relativity theory um
and and in all likelihood you know you
you have to tell them look just because
i no one believed einstein when he came
along you know
and and he changed the you know that
caused the paradigm shift
doesn't mean that you were also another
einstein with all due respect
yeah with all due respect you know that
he was one of a kind um
but you're right that the flip side is
that we overly respect someone
because they have a title or because you
know they they they they have expertise
in one area and we assume if it has the
whiff of science
then it must be true i mean i mean in in
in the commercial world in businesses
this is how they advertise stuff you
know you you know add a new yogurt or a
new face cream you add a scientific word
there actually scientists have said you
know and therefore it becomes the truth
uh so we do
have to question
where the evidence comes so chances are
if someone's dedicated their life to a
subject
then i would give them the benefit of
the doubt i wouldn't assume that i
shouldn't trust anything they say
because they may have alternate ulterior
motives they may have ulterior motives
they may you know maybe saying something
because their pain masters want them to
or because they want to promote a
particular theory because they've
invested their lives in it even though
it's wrong
there's a good chance that if you're an
expert you probably know more than
someone who just
comes up with some opinion
you know turn someone into a scientist
you know just based on their pure
passion like you said curiosity you know
my uh i'm curious about conspiracies
myself sometimes uh we'll get to those
later in the next interview
but uh can you really convert you know
teach someone to be a scientist can you
can you start and and if so how how
would you how do you do that
absolutely you can i mean being a
scientist
we are not a separate species from the
rest of humankind you know
we are people who you know we're all
curious as children and we ask the why
questions
most people as they grow up they you
know they they got to get on with their
lives they got to get a job and a
mortgage and a family and all that you
know the challenges of daily life and
they stop asking those why questions
they stop being curious about how why is
the world the way it is they don't have
that luxury those of us who are trained
in science it becomes our job to keep
asking those questions so we remain
curious
but training someone to become a
scientist is not is nothing special it's
about showing how we do science it's
about you know the scientific method
being you know two of the most important
things are
never being completely certain about
something always allowing
a place for doubts to change your mind
and also being prepared
to admit when you're wrong
you know and i said that's the
difference between a good scientific
theory and a conspiracy theory ask a
conspiracy theorist what evidence would
it take for me to persuade you to change
your mind and they would have to admit
nothing nothing would by definition a
conspiracy theorist it's it that's their
whole reason for believing what they
believe because nothing is going to
dissuade it whereas a scientist a good
scientist
has to be prepared to say
i was wrong
i thought this theory this hypothesis
this i could explain this phenomenon
you've presented me with data uh or some
observational evidence that suggests i'm
wrong i had to change my mind not all
scientists i mean not all scientists do
that right not all scientists are good
but that's the way it should work and i
don't see any reason why anyone couldn't
learn
to to think in that way
in that way right now when you hear
things like trust the science i want to
pivot now to uh actually what i
understand is that it came out of the
covid pandemic which unfortunately
you're suffering from but you're
recovering from and you should have a
swift full recovery uh in time uh uh for
dinner and
but um you know code came out and i
recall things in the uk uh professor
ferguson the rival institution another
coming out with uh models predicting
dire you know numbers of deaths uh you
know in very short period of time and
eventually maybe that'll prove to be
correct and similarly you mentioned
global climate change and global warming
um a lot of this
is based on extremely complex physics
and if at all if it is linear if we can
actually be reductionist and say that
well a virus is just biology biology is
just chemistry chemistry is just cell
you know physics et cetera et cetera at
some level physicists should be able to
do stuff and yet
we get a lot of things wrong uh when we
turn to models talk about like what is
the role of a model in science and not
the runway kind of which you certainly
could be
um
one of the guests i thought i'd have the
a radio show on on the bbc the the life
scientific which uh which has been going
for many years in which i interview
other other scientists and um
i remember interviewing a climatologist
tamzin edwards very sp smart scientist
who you know works on mathematical
models and she has a website and a blog
which has the title all models are wrong
i forget who where the quote comes from
all models are wrong but some are more
useful than others right or something
like that so a model is a model it makes
a prediction and it's only as good as
whatever information you feed it in the
first place um
we do we try and develop our models to
make them more more sophisticated
we trust models more if you have two
very different computational models two
different sort of
imaginary pictures of of reality that
make the same predictions if they come
at some you know prediction about how
something will change and evolve like
how the what the climate would look like
50 years from now and they have
different
assumptions and inputs and yet both
points as the same thing happening
tends to make them it's a bit like doing
two different experiments in two
different labs and they both discover
the same phenomenon
that reproducibility
so a computer a computational model
is a is a
it's like doing an experiment in the lab
but with zeros and ones uh and you can
get it wrong in the same way that you
can get your experiment wrong
so some models are useful
but we shouldn't
we shouldn't trust that they are telling
us the truth but at the same time we
shouldn't dismiss them out of hand
simply because
one day they we might find that they're
incomplete they're incomplete right and
i think that's all well and good when
you're looking at you know the
millennium simulation of structure
formation in the early universe or
you're looking at you know how uh
certain you know primates you know
evolved and got out of africa um but you
know the other hand when it impacts you
know the layperson in their daily life
things like climate change things like
viral you know epidemiology
if you can't trust these people who as
you say rightfully so have dedicated
their lives to this career i mean um
does it do confident people having
confidence in science um when they will
if anything know when people get models
wrong rather than right yeah i think
for one thing is people need to
understand
how science works and that's something
that has happened to some extent over
the course of the last two years of the
pandemic people have seen the scientific
method in action and i've seen these
modelers saying
this is going to happen or you know the
way to stop yourselves from catching
covert is to you know to wash your hands
i know this was the same thing in the
u.s but in the uk it was there was the
mantra washed your hands while singing
happy birthday twice through right
you're that that length of time you know
and then you know a few months later
washing your hands isn't so important
you've got to wear a mask or you've got
a ventilation and so so people who don't
understand how science works said hang
on you guys just told told me that i
could avoid catching coconut washing my
hands now you're saying i've got to wear
a mask you know nothing you know
but if people understand how science
works say well no this is in the light
of new evidence we need to be able to
backtrack to change our minds to you
know to to revise our view
what
also is important particularly for
something like climate change
i think is that we have to apply the
precautionary principle that we know
we're never going to be sure
that
you know the climate is going to change
in this way or all that is going to lead
to these dire consequences
but in all likelihood it's going you
know there's the the famous example that
you know 97 of climatologists say you
know we humans have changed their
climate
there must have been some surveys some
years ago the 97 percent of you know and
and then people say well hang on a
minute so you're not sure so there's
three percent of good scientists who
argue
they're doing so maybe you're wrong if
you go to your doctor and and your
doctor says
you know if you don't give up drinking
and smoking and change your diets you
know you're going to be dead in five
years and you say well doctor how sure
are you well i can't be sure i'd say 97
sure you're not going to turn around and
say oh okay i'm going to seek a second
opinion because you're not sure you
adopt a precautionary principle and say
chances are you're right better safe
than sorry we should do something about
it so and that's how i feel about
climate change chances are
it's it think things are going going
badly wrong and we need to do something
about it maybe we don't have to but we
can't afford not to do something
yeah one of the powerful takeaways you
know from the book and from you know
conversations i've heard on the live
scientific and elsewhere is that um you
know when you say something when a
scientist says i don't know
it doesn't mean like everything's
equally likely you know it doesn't mean
like i don't know what's going to happen
with you know it doesn't mean like
covets nothing or it's everything or
global change um and yet again when it
does impact you know the ordinary person
i feel like you and i let's i just want
to toot our own horns for a second we
get paid by the taxpayer at some level
to do a job we would do for free i mean
don't tell gavin newsom my boss but i
would do it for percentage
but i would do it for free right uh i
don't know about you um but i assume
that you would because you have so much
joy literally that's the reason i think
you use out of the title right so it's
pleasurable we get paid so on what other
job you know if you if you are the
plumber and uh and you come over to fix
the house and the plumber tells you uh
you can't understand what i'm doing it's
very complicated and she's right you
know she's actually very a student knows
plumbing she's done her dedicated whole
life to plumbing as you said
but yeah if she tells you you can't
understand it it's very complicated and
as you quote fineman saying in the book
you know if i could explain why i won
the nobel prize it would be worth a
nobel prize on the other and another day
he said if you don't if you can't
explain it to your grandmother you don't
understand it's like which is it fineman
yeah anyway
to what extent do you believe or maybe
disagree i'll state what i believe i
think it's a moral obligation that we
scientists have and that we fail
miserably at half the time because we're
so busy
but we have to tell the public in terms
they can understand what we're doing
with their money that they've given us
this treasure to do what we would do for
free what how how have you you because
you obviously are one of the master
communicators who've ever lived i mean
actually because of your huge impact bbc
and in america and netflix and
all the places you've had an outsize
impact did you have training what is
your underlying philosophy of doing that
essential outreach which is to the
benefit of science so we can keep
getting funds to do what we love in all
honesty i don't do my science
communication altruistically because i
feel i have a moral obligation for the
world to be more scientifically literate
i do it because it gives me joy
you know i i've always said that
i don't want just to be a science
communicator talking about other other
people doing the science i want to be a
scientist who communicates but when i
find out something
fascinating about the world why why
wouldn't i want to shout it from the
rooftops why wouldn't i want to tell
everyone about it so i i
when i communicate science when i'm
explaining something and to to someone
who doesn't have the the background
expertise they're not dumber than me you
know this idea that we said we are
dumbing down in order for people to
understand that's not they're not
they're not dumber than me they just
haven't had the benefit of years of
dedicated thinking about this stuff that
i have
and and so
getting an idea across in a way that i
think they can understand sure i'm i'm
going to probably leaving out i'll be
leaving out some of the details of the
algebraic derivation that are not
important in getting the concept across
but it gives me genuine pleasure to see
that
penny drop the light bulb come on
i see now i get i get the same sort of
tingle or enjoyment of someone
understanding something i've expected
that i got when i first learned that
about that so so i i do my science
communication because i i enjoy it
personally although of course i
acknowledge you're right you know we
have a moral obligation not every
scientist is good at communicating
science the same as not every you know
some scientists in in academia are
better research others are better at
teaching uh you know and you know horses
for courses but those who can
communicate those who are who want to
you know like like you and me you know
who want to sort of get across these
ideas and and empower society and
enthuse
absolutely we have to do it because
that's you know this is not some this is
not something that we should be keeping
to ourselves
keeping to ourselves no it's too much
fun yeah it's magic that's real right
yeah right
what uh going magical even further and
we'll get to arthur c clarke's you know
famous laws later on you mentioned
arthur c clarke in the book i found that
delightful uh but um i want to ask you
what's the biggest source of hype right
now in physics or science in general
what is the biggest perhaps most
overblown thing in science that's uh
falls in the category of hype
i think it might be when we we talk
about the
uh the opportunities with quantum
technologies and and quantum computing
for example
um i think
the impression that the public gets is
that quantum computers are going to you
know to to replace our current computers
and they can do everything so much
quicker and better the same with with
artificial intelligence you know that's
that we are
years maybe decades but maybe only just
years away from artificial general
intelligence and and machines that can
become conscious
you know those that sort of hype
i can understand why because they're
exciting and you know hollywood
gets you know it makes a good living out
of the science fiction movies that based
on those themes but it does give people
themes but it does give people the wrong
impression that we're getting we're
approaching this
the wonderful these technologies that
are that are probably not we're not
going to see in our in our lifetime
right um you know so i think that
in in a few decades ago there's a lot of
hype and theoretical physics that we
were coming to the end of theoretical
physics you know that the large hadron
collider would discover all sorts of new
particles that we we you know that we're
approaching a theory of everything and
stephen hawking wrote an article about
40 years ago about you know the end of
theoretical physics just got to dot the
eyes across the t's
and
no actually we're a long way off we
don't even know what dark matter is made
of
so there was that hype i think we've
we've sort of
um sobered up a bit from that we realize
we have a long way to go in
understanding the nature of reality but
in the technologies that we that are
being promised now i think that there's
a good deal of hype that's uh that we
should also try to try and pull back
from
quantum technology just a plug for next
week's episode is with uh dr nicole
younger halpern about quantum
information her book is called uh
quantum steampunk which is delightful
and she talks about that in our
interview which you'll hear next week so
please do subscribe to the channel uh
and hit the like button if you like
conversations like we're having with jim
today uh you'll definitely like nicole's
interview about her book next week it's
just funny that you mentioned it because
we did talk about that and it's it's
sort of like what i say about string
theory you know string theory's the best
theory ever made to describe the
properties and possibilities of string
theory and it seems like quantum
computers are really good as feynman
predicted at like unraveling how quantum
computers work and how lagrangians work
but in my field you know cosmology we
hear about the multiverse i even had on
david chalmers i talked about the
simulation hypothesis are these things
that um physicists use to generate you
know clicks and eyeball i certainly do
that by the way i mean uh this the this
episode will be called you know jim el
clay tells all in a way that he's never
told it before
uh
cobia free and loving it covid was a 5g
ruse no no i'm not gonna do that don't
worry uh but um but in reality you know
we kind of do you know there's a
universe running backwards in time i
just saw in the guardian last week you
know um to what extent does that uh is
that playful it's in good fun or can it
really detract from the public support
they find out like well didn't you guys
claim neutrinos travel faster than the
speed of light that appeared on page one
of the new york times the retraction
appears on page you know this b17 on the
weekend edition six months later so what
responsibility do we have i've said we
should have a pr budget i i'm fully
aware we should have a p but we should
have a retraction budget as well like
how do you deal with the self-correcting
essence of science would you touch upon
so heavily in this book science is
self-correcting that's often wrong
never in doubt maybe but how do we
correct in a way that shows the public
that we're honest integrity but we also
make mistakes
yeah it's difficult when when it comes
to subjects that you know the sexier
parts of science things like you know
the cosmology or particle physics or
advances in genetics or artificial
intelligence because you know the the
media and journalists even if they're
good science journalists
they they want the headlines they want
the the clicks you know they want to
infuse and they don't care if you know
as you say you know a month or two down
the line it turns out that that was that
was just wrong you know it's too late
you know you've got people excited
in in some respects i think it's good to
enthuse the the wider public with the
excitement of science you know it
happened back where the in 2008 when the
large hadron collider was turned on and
then the run-up to it you know people
say oh you can turn down this particular
celery so much energy you're going to
create a black hole that's going to
swallow up the earth
and a lot of my colleagues were
horrified by that that's that's just bad
science well yeah it's bad science but
you you've got people in bars talking
about particle physics and you know
but you then have to follow it up right
you have to you have to follow up
to to make sure that people's
expectations of what science is going to
deliver are realistic
these are exciting things they're
they're they're you know fizzing our
imagination
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
you know they are correct because that
you're right you know because then if
you know a few months down the line say
oh no no you know we we thought there
was a there
there was inflation and there isn't or
we thought there were parallel universes
and well you know what do we believe so
we've got it we've got to ex
in explaining the the excitement and and
the the coolness of some of the science
that we do
we also have to explain how we do
science
part of that is to say that look this is
a hypothesis you know we don't know we
haven't tested it you know string theory
is very neat and powerful maths but that
doesn't mean that you know there are ten
dimensions of vibrations that may turn
out to be wrong um is it science yes
it's still science you know cosmology
and multiverse even if something isn't
testable
doesn't mean it's
it's metaphysics or philosophy or
theology it's still part of science so
just we haven't figured out how to test
it yet right i'm more optimistic in that
way one day we might be able to say
whether string theory is right or wrong
but until then it's it's it's it's nice
maths
it's nice maths yeah and if you say
something is settled science that to me
closes off the possibility that a young
you know alberta einstein or you know
will come along and and solve this great
problem uh that you actually were wrong
about but you didn't know it because you
felt uh that's a much better outcome you
know we we didn't want the higgs boson
to be discovered right because that
meant new physics to be here oh okay it
is it's there after all tick that box
yeah i mean the experimentalists wanted
it to be there
listen if you spent 20 years building a
lot the largest particle accelerator in
the world yeah you want to find
something
at speaking of which i'm going to have
frank close on uh soon right good fun
yes yes he wrote a great new book called
elusive about peter higgs kind of a bio
of him scientific but also popular bio
of him um so one of the delightful
chapters that i really loved uh is
entitled uh chapter seven is entitled
don't be afraid to change your mind i
want to ask you jim what have you
changed your mind about
in in my area of research so i started
off i don't work so much in nuclear
reaction theory now but i started my phd
was into studying modeling nuclear
reactions and i was i remember was
looking at particular type of atomic
nucleus and how the protons and neutrons
are arranged and i had developed a model
to calculate cross sections so the
chances that a particle hitting another
was going to bounce off at a certain
angle
and and i developed a
a model published papers on it
and then
realized that what i was doing wasn't
wasn't the complete picture and i
remember having a a running battle with
a rival group of researchers and so we'd
like to stand up in conferences and
you know you you know i could ask this
question
and i think both of us realize that the
other guy was also right and that
somehow we had to find a compromise
um and so you know you you do that in
science you you have a view an idea or
you develop a theory you publish papers
you have to be prepared
to you know to admit at some point that
that is not you know the end of the
story that you may have an incomplete
picture
more recently
um i don't like admitting this but i i
hated the many worlds interpretation the
everest interpretation of of quantum
mechanics one of the ways of explaining
you know what is going on in the quantum
world
i reluctantly i blame
yeah people like sean carroll because
they are
so so persuasive
but but i i have to admit that i'm sort
of thinking
yeah it's it is quite appealing it i i'm
i'm not as against many worlds as i used
to be and i'm i'm saying this publicly
now maybe for the first time so i may
live to regret
my words but yeah you have you have to
be prepared that's you know that's what
science is about it's not about
holding on to to a cherished eye holding
on to to a cherished idea or view or
ideology that's why it's different from
politics or religion or
in science it's it's about the way the
world is and if someone tells you it's
not the way you thought it was you have
to accept that yeah yeah exactly
uh so we're coming close to the end of
your a lot of time and i have a few more
questions for myself that i'll wrap up
with but i want to answer at least a few
audience questions and we're starting
with one uh
from a
young very shy very unknown scientist by
the name of sabina hassenfelder who
who endorsed your book your lovely book
blair belong with she's a past guest an
upcoming guest for her new book
existential physics subscribe if you
want to catch that episode that'll be a
live in person episode not live but
it'll be in person
and then uh my best one of my best
friends uh sylvester james gates of
brown university blurbed it as well but
sabine asked the following question
what's the most exciting area of physics
so it's kind of the the contra pass to
the to the what's the biggest hype she
wants to know what do you think is the
most exciting area of physics or science
it could be all of science well it
depends on what the most exciting area
for me or the most exciting area
that i think other people think
is for you for me well for me when
people look for a theory of everything
we're working in in
quantum gravity they're trying to unify
two of the big pictures in physics you
know the quantum mechanics that
describes the world of the very small
and general relativity describing the
the word the cosmic scale and and as we
know you know they're struggling to find
the correct picture whether it's string
theory or loop quantum gravity or some
other idea
for me what is exciting is unifying
quantum mechanics with
another pillar of physics which is
thermodynamics
so for me the most exciting thing is is
this new new um area of of quantum
thermodynamics
and that is so appropriate because as i
said next week nicole younger is on
discussing
that yeah so thank you for setting me up
there you go
you know in quantum information theory
quantum thermodynamics the the uh um
far from equilibrium statistical
mechanics all those ideas to do with
things like the nature of time itself
i find is the most exciting you know
where does the arrow of time come from
where does the irreversibility of time
come from when down at the quantum world
even and indeed in the newtonian world
the equations are reversible in time so
where does that direction in time come
from
exists in thermodynamics it's it points
in the direction of increasing entropy
increasing disorder
how how does that link in with quantum
mix so for me what's exciting is trying
to
blend together mesh together quantum
mechanics and thermodynamics there are
people who've spent years thinking about
this i'm sort of coming to it quite
green
but i've bought the textbooks i've
started reading the papers i've got a
couple of postdocs working on it that's
what's giving me a buzz at the moment
okay this is a question from my youtube
channel so reminder you can ask
questions of all my guests
on my youtube channel which is dr brian
keating and this one is from nicholas
paulsen it's uh it's more of a statement
uh and he says don't miss the book
called the science of joy by jim's
brother jim acetely
acetaly not alkali
um i didn't know you had a brother i did
i didn't nor did i know that he'd
written the book so similar entitled to
mine
he's an alkaline uh he's a he's an acid
that's the guy
uh so the last question from the
audience from my friend who goes by the
moniker memes of destruction which i was
actually going to choose for one of my
kids names
he says i keep caring about an
anti-universe
might this or some hidden phenomenon
help explain the similarity between
gravity and electromagnetism
can an anti-universe maybe this universe
that runs backwards in time could that
somehow explain
equational simplicity or similarity
between maxwell's equations and
einstein's equations i don't really know
well i don't know i mean it's difficult
to say what is the similarity between
maxwell's equations and isola's
equations other than the fact that we
can describe them both in terms of
fields you know we have a gravitational
field we have electromagnetic field
but the whole um difficulty in finding a
theory of quantum gravity is unifying
uh quantum field theory which
encompasses the electromagnetic force
with general relativity which is
gravity so
the problem in modern physics is how
gravity and electromagnetism come
together now einstein was working
towards this but he wasn't working he
wasn't doing it at a quantum level you
know the idea that
there were ideas back in the early 20th
century due to colusa and klein
suggesting that um
you know there is a connection between
gravity and electromagnetism and you
need another dimension to to bring them
together
but the notion that an anti-universe i
don't even know what an anti-universe
means a universe made of antimatter or
is it universe running backwards in time
yeah they're interesting ideas but i
think it's that there are too many
concepts that we're trying to sort of
put together logically here to make
sense of
okay well jim we've reached the
regularly uh scheduled question limit
and now we're gonna break here gonna
create a separate video where jim is
gonna answer the thrilling three
patented thrilling three questions about
existential meaning and wisdom
so you'll have to subscribe to the
channel and over on my newsletter
brianketing.com to get that i'll have
links to jim's uh phenomenal output and
all of his tv specials and of course the
life scientific
jim thank you so much and please stick
around for a few more minutes of
existential questions my pleasure okay
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
and i know if you loved this video
you're going to enjoy this special
playlist which i've created just for you
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and leave a comment in the section
below
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you